how's it going everybody so we finally
got the Avengers end game trailer and it
was awesome but with the trailer
obviously came many many questions and I
think one of the biggest questions that
is out there right now concerning this
trailer is who is going to save Iron Man
there are already tons of theories out
there concerning who's gonna save him
some say Pepper Potts on the rescue
armor some say Captain Marvel and many
many others but in this video I want to
talk about a personal theory of mine
about how I think that Ant Man Scott
Lang is going to be the one that truly
saves Iron Man also I'm giving away a
life-size Infinity Gauntlet all you have
to do to enter for your chance to win is
subscribe to my channel like the video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
we had the scene in The Avengers in-game
trailer with Scott Lang knocking on the
front gate of the Avengers facility and
a lot of people were shocked because the
last time that we saw ant-man he was
stuck inside of the quantum realm but we
knew that he was going to get out so
that's not as much of a shock as it is
that he's at the Avengers facility in
the current time right after tano's a
snap because we know that's exactly when
he got stuck inside of the quantum realm
so we know in the post-credits scene of
ant-man
and the wasp Janet Van Dyne mentions a
time vortex and right now this is the
most logical explanation of how ant-man
could get out of the quantum realm he's
going to get stuck inside of the quantum
realm and everybody who knows that he's
inside the quantum realm currently just
got turned to dust there may still be
some of his friends or possibly his
daughter alive but they're not gonna
know where he is and even if they do
they're not gonna know how to get him
out so the time vortex just makes the
most sense but he's not going to go
through a time vortex and end up in the
same time that he just currently left
he's going to go through the time vortex
and end up in a different time and no
matter what time he goes to there's
going to be somebody that can help him
out if he goes to the past he could
simply go and find Hank Pym or if he
goes even further back in time than that
he could simply go and find a quantum
physicist but if he goes forward in time
there will still be people alive such as
banner that could probably help him
figure out how the quantum realm works
but here's the thing whoever he runs
into will most likely only be able to
help him get back in the quantum
so there's a good chance that he's going
to have to go back into the quantum
realm and find another time vortex go
out of that and keep doing that until he
ends up back to his current time and
here's where I think he's going to be
the one who really saves Iron Man as he
jumps through these multiple time
vortexes he will eventually end up in
the future and I think he will end up in
a future where Ironman is actually dead
an in-game teaser trailer we see nebula
touching Tony shoulder and if you
noticed the way that she touches his
shoulder is really kind of like she's
saying goodbye and even before that when
she enters the room she kind of enters
like she doesn't know if he's going to
be alive or if he's going to be dead so
his food and water ran out four days ago
like he said in the trailer and then he
said the next day his oxygen would run
out nebula being pretty much a machine
doesn't need any of those things to
survive so I think Tony actually does
die and when ant-man winds up in the
future I think it's a future where Tony
is dead so he'll obviously come to a
future where everything is completely
different because of the snap so once it
gets to the future of course he'll go
and try to find Captain America or
another one of the Avengers and they'll
explain everything that happened Thanos
the Infinity stones the battle in
Wakanda everything but I think at this
point in time that ant-man winds up in
Tony will be dead but somebody would
have found his ship already on the ship
they'll find his helmet with his
recorded message to pepper so they'll
know he was stranded in space and
they'll know that he was somewhere
around Titan but from here ant-man can
explain the quantum realm and the time
vortexes and now ant-man knows that Tony
was stranded in space and he died in
space due to a lack of food water and
oxygen so when he finally gets back to
the current time right after the snap he
can go to the Avengers facility and find
Captain America just like we saw in the
trailer and when he finally gets there
he can tell them that Tony is lost in
space and is dying and from there they
can send somebody to save him because
they know that he's dying they know he's
stranded in space and they know that
he's around Titan and once they get to
Titan they're probably close enough to
where they can track his suit or they
can track a ship and there's many ways
to save him pepper can take a ship and
then Don the rescue armor and go save
him we know that Thor is with the rest
of the Avengers now and that
Stormbreaker has the power to summon the
Bifrost so he could go save him and
there's just many different ways and
many different people who could say
I'll do that in another video but I
think the way they save him is that
ant-man ends up in a future where Tony
Stark is dead takes that information
back to the current time tells them and
they send somebody out to find him
because you have to keep in mind that
Tony said his food and water ran out
four days ago and his oxygen is about to
run out as well so he's right about the
die and a lot of people have said like
maybe Captain Marvel will run into him
on the way to earth but I really think
it looks like nebula is touching him
that delicate way because he actually is
already dead so even if Captain Marvel
runs into the ship I think he might
already be dead so I think that ant-man
is going to be the one that truly saves
him because he finds out that he died in
space and he finds out that he was close
to Titan and from there they can send
somebody to save him but this is just my
theory let me know what you all think of
it and let me know if you have any
theories of your own let me know in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe like the video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything related to Avengers in game
as always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]